Now it's your turn to build
the temperature unit setting.
This will bring together a lot
of the concepts that you've learned
and will take some time to implement,
but we think you're ready for it.
Modify the app so that
the right temperature units
are displayed to the user.
Use the assumption
that we're syncing
metric data from the server.
Eventually, we'll have a database
on the device and we don't want
a mix of Fahrenheit
and Celsius data in there.
Hence, we'll stay consistent
by getting metric data from the server.
And then we'll convert
on the fly to the preferred units
when we update the UI.
After you make these changes,
I'll show you what it
looks like on the device.
If you go to settings, you'll see
the temperature units preference.
If you tap on that,
you see a dialog with two options.
If you switch to imperial
and then you go back
to the forecast list, then you see
that all the temperatures
now are in Fahrenheit.
Once it works, answer this question.
Which subclass of preference did you use?